un grand rendez-vous pour la mode
aujourd'hui à Paris où se tient le Salon
du prêt-à-porter 70 fabricants plus de
5000 modèles France roche vous présente
sa sélection
ni le journaliste de mode ne cesse de
traverser Paris entre la Porte de
Versailles et les halles pour la Grande
Semaine du prêt-à-porter un prêt à
porter qui se porte mal car il souffre
de la concurrence étrangère il souffre
également d'un manque de flexibilité
dans ces procédés de fabrication et dans
ces modalités d'emploi il n'y a pas une
mode il y a des modes et les sinistres
les fabricants proposent plusieurs
thèmes pour l'hiver ce sera le style
british ce sera le style Lama c'est à
dire voyez la Cordillère des Andes ce
sera le style lapon au ski voyez
rembourrage le style militaire pas
besoin d'explication et puis le style
Venise c'est-à-dire volant et dentelle
pour l'été le cours jupe courte pantalon
court le style latino américain le style
safari vous voyez l'Afrique puis surtout
beaucoup de bleu blanc rouge est-ce
l'influence des élections
un raccourci